From the studio that made a movie about a bee
in an interspecies relationship with a lady,
comes a fantasy adventure so solid
it will almost make you forget
Dreamworks made a movie where a bee falls in love with a lady
I mean, he's a bee !
And she's a lady !
How is that supposed to even work ?
It's physically impo-
Wait.
What movie were we talking about again ?
How To Train Your Dragon 1 and 2
Visit the magical land of Berk
A place full of happy vikings
and happy dragons,
and when they team up,
you can assume they'll bring untold pain and carnage to the rest of the world
So let's turn the ??? back to family-friendly
to experience the saga, the unlikely hero :
Hiccup
He didn't inherit his father's viking strength
or his viking... scottish accent ?
But he's got more
Still funnier than Funny People
Everything will change when he meets Toothless
a dragon crossed with all your favorite cat videos
They'll prove that working together makes people stronger
and their friendship will transforms Berk
from a land that used to hate and fear dragons
to one that uses them for Quidditch or something
I mean, progress is progress, right ?
Meh, whatever
Look how cute he is !
Aw
Strap in as Hiccup teams up with his pals: Astrid and the Warriors 4
Who even have less character development than ? and the Warriors 3
Like the boy one,
the nerd one,
the other girl one,
and the other boy one
Man, what a waste of Jonah Hill
Where is that Mc'lovin?
Its hard to say
Together that'll take you deeper into the world of dragons
Whether its discovering that dragons are all drones serving a bigger dragon
Or, that dragons are all drones serving a bigger dragon
Or, that bigger dragons can fight over who gets to make dragons into drones serving of bigger dragons
Huh, there's actually very little dragon training in the entire franchise
Then again, how to prevent the submission of your dragon to the will of a homicidal apex predator doesn't have quite the same ring to it
So if you want a fantasy series for all ages
That swaps out Dreamwork's usual pop-culture references for some actual heart
Make sure to check out some of the best modern fantasy movies today,
That aren't most of the Harry Potter movies
Or Lord of the Rings
Or terrible
How to Train Your Dragon! It's the best of whats left!
Starring
The Boy With The Dragon How-To
This Is... Scotland ?
No Arm-ie Hammer
Lydia
Dragonforce
Mother Of Dragons
DRAGOOOOO!
Yawn Snow
And
Dragon Bawl Me
*cries and hiccups*
I'm gonna need a second
How To Prevent The Submission Of Your Dragon To The Will Of A Homicidal Apex Predator
See ? Not catchy
Very true, T.J Miller, very true